dès demain tout le territoire à
l'exception de mayotte et de la guyane
où le virus circule encore activement
tout le territoire donc passera dans ce
qu'il est désormais convenu d'appeler la
zone verte ce qui permettra notamment
une reprise plus forte du travail et la
réouverture des cafés et restaurants en
ile de france
dès demain il sera à nouveau possible de
se déplacer entre les pays européens et
à partir du 1er juillet nous pourrons
nous rendre dans les états hors d'europe
où l'épidémie sera maîtrisée dès demain
en hexagone comme en outre mer
les crèches les écoles les collèges se
prépareront à accueillir à partir du 22
juin
tous les élèves de manière obligatoire
et selon les règles de présence normal
il faudra continuer d'éviter au maximum
lé rassemblement car nous savons qu'ils
sont les principales occasions de
propagation du virus
ils resteront donc très encadrée le
second tour des élections municipales
pourra se dérouler dans les communes
concernées le 28 juin
enfin pour nos aînés en maison de
retraite ou en établissement les visites
devront désormais être autorisé cela ne
signifie pas que le virus a disparu et
que nous pouvons baisser totalement
lagarde
il nous faudra pour longtemps encore
vivre avec lui respecter les règles de
distance physique l'été 2020 ne sera pas
un été comme les autres et il nous
faudra veiller à l'évolution de
l'épidémie pour nous préparer au cas où
elles reviendraient avec plus de force
la lutte contre l'épidémie n'est donc
pas terminée mais je suis heureux avec
vous de cette première victoire contre
le virus
nous n'avons pas à rougir mes chers
compatriotes de notre bilan
des dizaines de milliers de vies ont été
sauvées par nos choix
par nos actions
bien sûr cette épreuve a aussi révélé
des failles des fragilités notre
dépendance à d'autres continents pour
nous procurer certains produits non
lourdeur d'organisation nos inégalités
sociales et territoriales
je veux que nous tirions toutes les
leçons de ce que nous avons vécu avec
l'épidémie l'économie mondiale s'est
quasi arrêter notre première priorité
est donc d'abord de reconstruire une
économie forte écologique souveraine et
solidaire depuis le premier jour de la
crise notre mobilisation est totale
quoi qu'il en coûte tel est l engagement
que j'avais pris devant vous dès le mois
de mars
ces dépenses se justifier et se justifie
en raison des circonstances
exceptionnelles que nous venons de venir
mais elles viennent s'ajouter à notre
dette déjà existantes
nous ne financerons pas ses dépenses en
augmentant les impôts notre pays est
déjà l'un de ceux où la fiscalité la
plus lourde
même si depuis trois ans nous avons
commencé à l'abaisser la seule réponse
est de bâtir un modèle économique
durable plus fort de travail et de
produire davantage pour ne pas dépendre
des autres nous unir autour du
patriotisme républicain est une
nécessité sommes une nation où chacun
quelles que soient ses origines sa
religion doit trouver sa place est ce
vrai partout et pour tout le monde non
notre combat doit donc se poursuivre
s'intensifier pour permettre d'obtenir
les diplômes et les emplois qui
correspondent au mérite des talents de
chacun et lutter contre le fait que le
nom l'adresse la couleur de peau
réduisent encore trop souvent dans notre
pays les chances que chacun doit avoir
je vous le dis très clairement ce soir
mes chers compatriotes la république
n'effacera aucune trace ni aucun nom de
son histoire
elle n'oubliera aucune de ses oeuvres
elle ne déboulonnera pas de statut
nous devons plutôt lucidement regarder
ensemble toute notre histoire
toutes nos mémoires nous ne bâtirons pas
davantage notre avenir dans le désordre
sans ordre républicain
il n'y a ni sécurité ni liberté cet
ordre ce sont les policiers et les
gendarmes sur notre sol qui l'assurent
ils sont exposés à des risques
quotidiens en notre nom
c'est pourquoi ils méritent le soutien
de la puissance publique et la
reconnaissance de la nation
j'en ai la conviction profonde
l'organisation de l'état et de notre
action doit profondément changer tout ne
peut pas être décidé si souvent à paris
c'est pourquoi je veux ouvrir pour notre
pays une page nouvelle donnant des
libertés et des responsabilités inédite
à ceux qui agissent au plus près de nos
vies liberté responsabilité pour nos
hôpitaux nos universités nos
entrepreneurs nos mères et beaucoup
d'autres acteurs essentiels